[Music]
well
now katy perry has another reason to
smile
the new mama just got a very special
congrats from
get this beyonce she is fascinating and
it's so inspiring to me
the 35 year old singer took to her insta
story tuesday to show off one
seriously lavish af floral arrangement
which featured some totally gorge white
orchids and roses
and if you're wondering what that card
says it reads
congratulations on the new addition to
your family
katie wrote on the pick i love you
beyonce yeah i think we can all agree on
that
bee is our queen a real regal
class act i'm proud of it i'm proud of
the hard work
but beyonce wasn't the only celeb to
send a sweet gift to katie
the pop star also shared this pic of a
box of champagne
and an adorable unicorn bathrobe from
her fellow american idol judge
lionel richie katie and her fiance
orlando bloom
welcomed their daughter daisy last week
and announced the news with this
pick writing alongside it quote we are
floating with love and wonder from the
safe and healthy arrival of our daughter
i mean i don't know who's going to come
first her or the record we'll see what
kind of headlines she wants she wants a
she wants to be the opener or the closer
i have a feeling she does not follow
yeah in addition to welcoming her
little one into the world katie also
released her new album
smile which she celebrated from her
hospital bed
tweeting quote delivering a baby and a
record in the same week
don't [ __ ] with mama let's go yes
noted oh thank you e.t caught up with
katie before her album was released
and before she gave birth and she
revealed
what kind of mama she wants to be
i'm just excited to be able to um
you know raise her
in a different way that i was raised and
to um
let her think for herself and have
choice
and you know discover and just
you know just lean into the magic of
life and and and probably
you know dress what like whatever she
wants to dress like for halloween
that's going to be really really
important i was never allowed to go
trick-or-treating
or no or dressing up that's probably why
i make up for it so much
yeah i was in church girl you know all
about it